[Music]
Disney Princesses have been around for a
while but it's not just their
personalities that have drastically
changed over time their fashion sense
also became different keep on watching
to see what our fave Disney Princesses
look like in modern clothing do you sing
when you wake up do you forest animals
help you with your chores if you're
basically a Disney princess be sure to
subscribe now let's get to the evolution
of Disney Princess fashion Snow White
the original Disney Princess has lips
red as the rose hair black as ebony and
skin as white as snow Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs was the very first
full-length Disney film which makes Snow
White the oldest of them all Snow White
was a princess under her stepmother the
Evil Queen the Queen is obsessed with
becoming the most beautiful woman in the
world so she has her Huntsman takes snow
white into the woods to kill her the
Huntsman cannot do it so he releases her
in the woods
Snow White finds a cottage and moves in
with Seven Dwarves the Evil Queen
disguises herself as an old woman and
poisoned Snow White with an apple Prince
Charming finds her and kisses her
breaking the spell it's a classic fairy
tale released in 1937 Snow White became
an icon to girls everywhere she's
dressed in her iconic yellow and blue
dress Snow White is originally a German
fairy tale so her outfit is inspired by
Renaissance German fashion her blue
bodice has puffy sleeves with red
peeking through she has a white collar
as was typical in the Renaissance Snow
White's physical appearance was inspired
by the movie stars of the 1930s she's
totally the fairest of them all
Cinderella 13 years after Snow White
Disney's second princess made her debut
Cinderella was a kind noble who was
forced to be a servant to her wicked
stepmother and stepsisters when she is
not allowed to go to the royal ball her
fairy godmother dresses her up in a
beautiful gown and glass slippers Oh
it's a beautiful Cinderella wins the
heart of the prince but she runs away
before her fashion spell is broken she
loses a glass slipper and the prince
travels the whole kingdom looking for
the girl it fits he finds Cinderella and
marries her it's the original rags to
riches story and young girls everywhere
fantasized about being whisked away in
becoming royal Cinderella was originally
a French fairy tale published back in
1697 you can see a lot of classic French
influences in the movie as well as in
Cinderella's fashion for most of the
movie she wears a traditional maid's
outfit with a brown bodice an apron for
the ball she looks a little closer to
Court fashion of the late 1600s in this
era skirts had large hoops which is why
her gown was so big she has seen in much
lighter colors than Snow White was and
the animators spiced up her outfit with
accessories like a simple black choker
Aurora for the third princess Disney
hopped back over to German fairy tales
Sleeping Beauty was released way back in
1959 Maleficent the evil sorceress shows
up to baby Aurora's christening
uninvited she curses Aurora to prick her
finger and fall into a deep slumber on
her 16th birthday in order to avoid this
Aurora is raised in the woods by three
good fairies she falls in love with
Prince Philip and goes to the castle
there Maleficent lures her away to a
spinning wheel she pricks her finger and
falls into the world's most epic nap
Prince Philip defeats Maleficent who can
turn into a dragon then he awakes Aurora
with true love's kiss it's sweet and
romantic and it's a classic Aurora's
design was originally based on Audrey
Hepburn a beautiful movie star of the
time the clothes she wears in the
forests look pretty similar to the made
clothes that Cinderella wore but her
ballgown looks like there are several
centuries older the fit of the bodice
and the skirt look very medieval but her
dress is off the shoulder which is more
of a Renaissance style she is also the
first princess to appear in pink she
also wears a similar blue to
Cinderella's dress because the fairies
argue over what color to make her gown
let's be honest the fairies are one of
the best parts of the whole movie Ariel
Disney left the princess game for a long
time after Sleeping Beauty it was 30
years until the next Disney princess
came on the scene can you believe that
The Little Mermaid assured in the next
stage of Disney Princesses Ariel is a
mermaid princess who is obsessed with
all things human Ariel falls in love
with the human Prince Erik and she
trades her voice to the evil sea witch
Ursula in exchange for legs Ariel and
Eric fall in love and they eventually
live happily ever after with Ariel
staying human the original fairy tale by
Hans Christian Andersen is dark af Ariel
has the total opposite of a happy ending
we'll stick with the Disney version as a
mermaid Ariel reveals a lot more skin
than previous princesses she looks like
a pretty traditional mermaid in her
green tail and purpose T she'll bra as a
human her fashion looks pretty close to
royal fashion of the mid-1800s her pink
dress has a hoop skirt and poppy sleeves
which is kind of a mix of Snow White and
Cinderella's guns she also wears a blue
gown with a long bodice and long sleeve
shirt underneath she's a Scandinavian
princess after all and it's not exactly
warm there the choice of pink and blue
dresses are a nod to earlier princesses
from the classic era Belle it's a tale
as all this time Beauty and the Beast is
one of the most popular Disney movies
ever
which makes Belle one of the most
popular princesses she's definitely one
of the most iconic that was the daughter
of an inventor in 18th century France
when her father is taken prisoner by an
evil Beast in an enchanted castle Belle
goes to rescue him take me instead she
offers herself in place of her father
with the help of all the magical
housewares fell on the beasts fall in
love this breaks the spell and the beast
is transformed into Prince Adam and they
live happily ever after
fellas diverse princess to break a magic
spell instead of the Prince breaking it
foul usually dresses in a blue peasant
dress with a white apron she wears her
hair in a low ponytail with a bow we are
seeing a trend with the bow dress it's
here her fancy ball gown is yellow a
color we have
see on a princess since no white it has
a giant hoop skirt which is typical of
that time period in France she wears
long yellow gloves and her dress is off
the shoulders this is not exactly true
to the air but it's one of the prettiest
Disney dresses ever it's no wonder that
her name means beauty jasmine our next
to Z Prince's might be one of the most
underrated princesses but she is really
important for Disney movies Jasmine from
Aladdin is the first non-white non
European Disney Princess and that is a
huge deal jasmine is the daughter of a
sultan which was an old title for King
in the Middle East she falls in love
with Aladdin thinking he is a prince and
he whisks her away on his magic carpet
she's fierce and independent and she
still loves Aladdin when she finds out
he's not Prince Ali because jasmine is
an Arabian princess her style is way
different from earlier princesses
she was designed to look like a
traditional Arabian royal she wears blue
harem pants and a matching top that
shows her midriff Disney is still
designing their princesses in blue at
this point her formal outfit is a purple
dress with a long pink veil
when Jafar takes her as prisoner he puts
her in a red harem style outfit and
there's a lot of controversy about the
rather creepy occult message those
scenes since whatever she wears jasmine
is a total fashion icon after jasmine
opened up a whole new world of Disney
Princesses Disney released Pocahontas a
movie that went in a completely new but
very appreciated direction then Disney
jumped to another side of the world and
gave us Mulan Mulan was based on an
ancient Chinese epic ballad to save her
elderly father from having to fight in
the war she disguises herself as a man
she quickly becomes an amazing soldier
and she saves all of China in the Disney
version she also falls in love with her
commander and lived happily ever after
of course it's a great movie all about
girl power and it's one of our faves
Disney really tried to depict the
Chinese Carowinds culturally accurate as
possible at the beginning of the movie
she is dressed for the matchmaker this
traditional Chinese dress is called a
han foo she's also made up in the
desired Chinese makeup fashion with a
pale face and exaggerated eyes and lips
which she hates and washes away through
most of the movie she dresses as a
traditional Chinese
older and while Milan is considered a
Disney princess she is actually the
first to not be royal by birth or
marriage
Tiana Disney took another long break
from Disney Princesses after Mulan but
in 2009 they released the princess in
the frog it was a huge deal because
Tiana became the first - black princess
she also continued the trend of Mulan
and Pocahontas by being a strong
independent woman she works hard to open
her own restaurant she is hired to make
food for a ball where the handsome
prince naveen will be but Naveen is
cursed into a frog Tiana kisses him and
instead of turning the bean into a human
she becomes a frog - they have to fight
a voodoo master to turn human again
although she spends most of the movie as
Anand Vivian Tiana has some amazing new
orleans-style as a waitress she wears a
simple yellow frock with an apron it's a
total nod to princesses like Cinderella
and Belle but in a brighter color her
most stylish gown is the one at the end
it's yellow and green and is inspired by
her Frog persona it's as big as Belle's
yellow gown but the green overlay
resembles a lily pad we think this is
some of the most creative fashion
designing to come out of Disney Rapunzel
after tiana Disney released tangled
which is a hilarious and awesome update
of the classic Rapunzel fairy tale
Rapunzel is the first CGI princess and
this story Rapunzel is stolen as a baby
by the evil Gothel Gothel uses
Rapunzel's magical hair to keep herself
young and beautiful she locks Rapunzel
in a tower when the Flynn Rider stumbles
on the tower after running from soldiers
Rapunzel convinces him to help her
escape she just wants to see the
floating lanterns during their adventure
Rapunzel and Flynn fall in love they
also learned the truth about Rapunzel's
past and together they defeat Gothel
she's naive like Ariel but independent
like Mulan it totally makes sense of
Rapunzel dresses a little like Aurora
after all they are both based on German
fairy tales
Rapunzel wears a traditional German
dress known as a dirndl it's pink and
purple with puffy sleeves which we see a
lot on Disney Princesses her hair is 70
feet long for most of the movie but when
she cuts it at the end she ends up with
a brown pixie cut that makes her look
way more modern than this story is no
matter her hair Rapunzel is one fierce
woman
Merida Merida from brave is the last
official Disney princess we know what
you're thinking what about Anna from
frozen
well according to the official Disney
princess line anna has not been included
as of 2018 Merida the daughter of King
Fergus and Queen Eleanor she's not a
traditional princess she hates being
ladylike girl we can relate she prefers
to spend her time outdoors and she's an
amazing Archer but because she doesn't
want to be all proper and get married
she and her mom have a really strange
relationship when her mom is turned into
a bear they have to learn to get along
and work together Merida is the first
and only princess who doesn't have a
love story in her movie and this makes
her awesome not everything is about
finding a husband after all Merida is
also difference in her fashion choices
she wears really dark colors which look
great with her fiery red hair
her dress is a pretty traditional
medieval dress but she wears her hair
loose instead of covered Merida really
stands apart from the rest of the Disney
Princesses and we think that makes her
even better there's no doubt that Disney
Princesses changed a lot from Snow White
to Meredith which Disney Princess
fashion is your favorite let us know in
the comments that's all we have for the
evolution of Disney princess fashion for
more Disney content check out our
community page and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]